he just doesn't seem to get along with
his kids very much anymore okay that's
what I'm seeing the reason I think he
started changing is because his kids
used to be young and now we're adults
and we have our opinions and we have our
adult thoughts so we have the things we
do as adults Sister Wives star Gwendolyn
Brown sees a change in her father Cody
along with some of her siblings and
she's revealing why it's more I'm not
the kind of person who I this is the way
that I am in my life the 21 year old
whom Cody shares with his ex Christine
opens up about it in a YouTube reaction
video about the TLC series when a fan
asks her to pinpoint why her dad's
demeanor changed on the show is it the
way he's been edited or has he changed
into the angry and patient foot stomping
man we see the reason I think he started
changing is because his kids used to be
young and now we're adults and we have
our opinions and we have our adult
thoughts so we have the things we do as
adults yeah and Gwen says he and several
of his kids are now estranged which fans
saw a glimpse of last season especially
when it came to Cody strict covid rules
because I can't leave my boys out
hanging out they're adults
bye bye you guys decide what you do
because I'm not going to tell this
family how they do it I am going to lead
the way that I think is the right way
and Gwen she attributes the estrangement
to this I think he just found it easier
to talk to them and they weren't as
opinionated we weren't as opinionated
and now we're adults and we have our
opinions and we have our adult thoughts
so we have the things we do as adults
and it's just different now I'm trying
to be a husband a father to their
children and that's a real challenge
meanwhile Gwendolyn has lots to smile
about over the weekend Christine shared
this pic with all her girls revealing
they celebrated Gwen's engagement to her
new fiance Beatrice it's been fabulous
Christine wrote in part it was so
wonderful to celebrate them